hey everyone welcome welcome welcome in
Market takes man I know you could have
been anywhere in the world but you're
here with me I appreciate that I am Dion
Rolan reporter at the Wall Street
Journal today we are breaking down the
jobs report nonfarm payrolls and man
this is an exciting one it's one of
those days where the data is showing a
lot of things the markets are moving all
around we got some big reactions I love
days like today so I appreciate you all
being with me today this report has very
good news and it has some very worrisome
news we are going to break it all down
right here on Market take so we're going
to talk about what the jobs report
showed and how it compared to
expectations talk about some standout
numbers from the report because there
was a lot to get into the market had
some strong reactions we are going to
talk about those Market reactions stock
bonds currencies big reactions in the FX
currency Market uh crypto Commodities
across the board you had some big moves
in the market in response to this jobs
data we're going to talk about all that
we are going to talk about how today's
data fits with some concerns about the
labor market that had been ongoing we
put out a video just yesterday on my
Channel about some weak signs underneath
the headline numbers in this jobs in the
uh the labor force that I've been seeing
and that other economists I talked to
have been seeing watch that if you
haven't uh it's on the channel and of
course we're going to talk about what's
next for data because we are always
looking forward even though it is
backward looking data so listen let's
get into it the jobs report for January
showed 353,000 jobs added last month and
the unemployment rate dropping to 3.7%
let's put a chart up here on your screen
right now so you can see what we're
talking about not just one month if you
look at the last three months we are
seeing a clear Trend you saw employment
gains kind of bottom out there in
October you had been seeing a decrease
right if you go to the left side of your
screen and you work to the right you're
seeing lower highs lower lows that was
the theme going into really the end and
the the fourth quarter of 2023 then we
hit that fourth quarter of 2023 and what
do you see you see those numbers start
to pick up on the right side of your
screen you're seeing a
reacceleration this month here this
January number the strongest we had seen
since January of last year now there's
some weird intricacies and changes in
terms of adjustments that the Bureau of
Labor Statistics makes to its data so we
don't want to get too far into that but
we see 353,000 jobs added in January you
see 333,000 jobs in December that was
revised up from
216,000 right you see 182,000 jobs added
in November that was revised up from the
previous month all of payroll employment
from 2023 was actually previously it was
225,000 jobs a month well now it's
255,000 jobs added per month in 2023
that is a significant revision so the
big thing here is not not just that this
month was a blowout number in terms of
way more than expected almost double the
expected rate and the unemployment rate
stayed low didn't pick up as expected
but those last three months or those
last two months excuse me were revised
higher and so we see an even stronger
pace of hiring and this chart just
illustrating again the overall theme it
had been lower now it's moving back
higher so that's what we're seeing we're
seeing a change in the regime a change
in the trend in terms of what's going on
with jobs but there is always a but
right when you're looking through the
data you got to read the fine print we
are going to dig into the fine print
right here on Market takes because
that's what we do there are some
indicators that are a cause for concern
let's talk a little bit about those
first one is Wages let's throw a chart
up here on your screen so you can see
what I'm talking about this is the
Atlanta fed's wage growth tracker now
what we had seen coming from 2021 out of
the pandemic 2022 started 2023
those wage gains just growing higher
folks getting five six 7% increases in
their wages and the average this is the
3month moving average right so this
really takes a lot of the noise out of
the data even with that even with a very
sober statistic like this Atlanta fed
wage growth tracker you just see a big
kind of hockey stick growth something
you really don't see you see downward
growth in that 2008 2009 going into
2010 that Global financial crisis the
great recess recession and you're seeing
just kind of the opposite of that out of
the pandemic recession and what you've
been seeing over the last few months
really we saw six straight months of
declines in wage growth and then you saw
a few straight months of that just being
flat and we've seen that flattening and
the question is are we going to rise
higher or are we going to continue to go
lower and that was a big question so
this chart just illustrating again where
wages had come from we've been going up
then we came back down and now we're
kind of stagnating well today's report
suggest that we could be going back up
average hourly earnings rose 0.6% that
was twice the expected rate now that
that turns out to a 4 and a half%
year-over-year increase in Wages that's
the highest since September so the FED
has said and fed share Jerome pow said
very clearly he wants the wages and he
wants uh earnings for us employees to
come back into a more normal pattern he
wants to see quote
normalization and that means wage growth
to come back down around where was uh
during most of the 2010s we're still
well above that but it looks like we
could be reaccelerating higher because
the wage gains we saw last month was
double the
expectation and puts us back on a
trajectory where we were in September
when wages were much higher here's the
other piece of that now that matters
because it puts pressure on inflation as
wages go higher you could see inflation
start to pick up and we did see last
month in the CPI inflation report
inflation picking back up to 3.4%
there also was a decline in labor force
participation and we're going to talk
about that in just a minute 175,000
people dropped out of Labor Force the
rate was unchanged but a few a lot of
people dropping out of the labor force
the mix of higher wages and fewer people
in the labor market that tends to put
more upward pressure on wages overall
we'll talk about that in just a minute
want to really quickly get a little
we're going to nerd out here just a
little bit talk about one quick thing
the household survey that happens when
the Bureau of Labor statistics calls you
up calls up people their house hey
what's going on man you got a job does
your wife have a job your kids more and
more we're hearing people say no I don't
have a job my wife doesn't have a job
Uncle Benji doesn't have a job Bobby
sleeping on the couch he ain't got a job
things are looking kind of rough we saw
the unemployment rate holding steady at
3.7% but that hold was for the wrong
reasons we saw the number of people
employed declined by 31,000 number of
people employed has now fallen in three
of the past last four months including a
decline of 683 th000 people in December
now the number of unemployed was down a
number of unemployed people fell by
144,000 but not because they got jobs
they didn't move to the employed
category right there's three categories
there's employed unemployed not in the
labor force all those folks employed was
moved net negative minus 31,000
unemployed minus 144,000 that equals the
175,000 people who were moved out of the
labor force so people dropping out of
the labor force and that accounts for
the decline in both employed people and
unemployed people so people aren't
getting jobs they're just saying they're
unemployed and the amount of time people
are spending unemployed is saying longer
we also have seen layups start to pick
up the Challenger job Cuts report showed
83 or
8237 cuts in January a
136% increase from the previous month
that's significant um really quickly be
aware my man Lou Breen he is the
economic strategist at drw trading he
says quote be aware that this month's
data has Benchmark revisions and
population updates in the two surveys
also just want to throw this out there
to disclaimer new revisions to the BLS
models and adjustments and also the last
three years the January jobs number has
been revised by literally hundreds of
thousands of jobs each month so when we
talk about that we're talking about
January 2021 was revised 10 times higher
the original report said 49,000 jobs
added by the time they made all the
revisions the monthly the annual the
revision that they just made it actually
was 494 th000 so from 49,000 the
original report to 49 494 th000 that
happened in January of 2022 and in
January of 2023 where we saw hundreds of
thousands of job differences between the
initial report and the revisions that's
significant now we want to talk about
significant let's take a look at what's
going on in the market I want to put the
markets up here on your screen this is
wsj.com this is our Market data as we're
seeing right now the S&P and the NASDAQ
still holding on to gains for the day
but you can see there is some
uncertainty there you see the the market
moving higher overall the Dow is lower
but we look at the S&P you saw that big
jump out of the gate and then you see
kind of coming down coming up
uncertainty the bond market now the
stock market you know me if you watch
Market takes ah you know the stock
market those are the Frat Bros of the
market the bond market this is where
we're seeing big moves the most traded
of all the treasury bonds this 10year
note right here and you see a huge jump
after the release of this jobs report
and now we are again moving higher so
those yields moving up that's a sign of
worries about inflation that's also
signs potentially more growth lots of
things baked into this but this kind of
move right here this doesn't happen on
its own this happens when there's a big
change in the data that we could be
seeing a regime shift and that's what
this jobs report tells us everyone was
expecting the FED to cut cut cut maybe
as soon as March fed share Jerome Powell
came out on Wednesday told us that's off
the table now it's looking like may may
may even be uncertain with all these job
gains this is a big move and on this
two-year note right here you are seeing
another significant move I also want to
take you back to this tenure right here
because the move we've seen in the price
change that's almost two full points
that is a huge move on the bond market
we're also seeing big moves in the
currency Market you're seeing the US
dollar Index again you see that same Big
Move that you saw on the yields
significant moves let's talk really
quickly about Commodities because what
we've seen here you're seeing across the
board in the red usually you don't see a
you know the same thing of these reports
on economic data moving the market for
Commodities this significantly we see it
right here this is all right around the
8:00 hour you see it in oil Futures you
see it in gold and that really is all
about you see it in silver as well
silver down about 2 and a half% right
now and that's all based on what's
happening in the dollar there are now
expectations for the value of the dollar
to rise all of these Commodities are are
measured in dollars so gold gold oil
copper all these things are priced in
dollars and when the value of the dollar
starts to rise the value of those
Commodities declines and that's what
we're seeing so we are seeing not just
the move in the dollar but the expected
future moves in the dollar really
pricing themselves out across the
commodity market and that just again
illustrating the move that and the the
strength and the importance of this jobs
report that we got today the market is
reacting in a big way and you can expect
to see those changes in the market
continue going forward um so let's talk
about the big picture right the FED said
on Wednesday fed share Jerome pal came
out and said we like what we're seeing
inflation is moving the way we want it
to the data is moving the way we wanted
to but we need to see more we need to
see more evidence that inflation is
coming down and will continue to come
down to our 2% Target and this year jobs
report it ain't it this is not it this
is not the evidence the FED is looking
for so we saw a big Market pullback you
saw the NASDAQ down 2% after the FED
came out and after fed share Jerome
Powell came out and very strongly put
some cold water on expectations for a
March rate cut we could be seeing a
similar transition or a similar Trend
play out again the stock market is again
still up right now especially the S&P
the NASDAQ trying to regain some of
those gains they lost on fed day but
keep an eye on a move today midday as
some of those big Traders start to come
in and start to rethink what this jobs
support means because again what we are
seeing is strength in terms of hiring
lots of hiring lots of jobs added but
there's a lot to be worried about within
this report so big question is just you
know the FED doesn't need to raise rates
to disrupt the market rally that we're
seeing the FED just needs to not cut
rates or not cut rates as quickly as the
market is pricing in fed chare Jerome
pal didn't say we're not going to cut
rates this year he just said we're
probably not going to cut them in March
well now May comes into question because
are they going to going to cut them in
May and if they don't cut them in May
maybe they don't cut in June maybe they
don't cut in July markets price was
pricing in six rate cuts for this year
fed only has 10 meetings they already
didn't do it once if they don't do it in
March that's twice that's eight meetings
for six rate Cuts you start to wonder
about the math and if the fed's not
going to cut rates significantly some of
these high valuations on the market
don't really make a lot of sense and
that's what the market could be thinking
about so let's talk let's get back to
this jobs report and some of the numbers
in there because I I talk about reading
the fine print let's talk about the fine
print throw a chart up here on your
screen about average hours average
weekly hours worked what do you see you
see a trend moving lower and then this
past month you see a significant Decline
and we actually remade this chart this
morning because the drop was so
significant we're seeing average average
weekly hours work drop to the lowest
since March 2020 you guys remember March
2020 not a good time and this just
illustrating you can see very clearly on
your screen we had been moving lower and
then we saw a significant move lower
it's it's small but when employers start
reducing hours that's a clear sign
there's worries about the overall labor
market there's clear signs there's
worried about the economy another sign
let's put up the labor force
participation rate there on your screen
what do you see you see it picking up
through 20121 2022 most of 2023 and then
uh oh what happened we're moving down
lower so like I said the labor force
participation rate didn't decrease this
month it held steady but we did see
175,000 fewer workers during the month
and that just illustrates again a
worrisome trend for the overall market
for the overall jobs Market uh right now
what we're seeing 175,000 people
dropping out a tight labor market with
3.7% unemployment should be bringing
more people in it should be adding
people but we are seeing consistently
fewer people employed we're seeing more
people moving out of the labor force
that's not good another thing into the
details of this report the number of
discouraged workers who are marginally
attached to labor force who believed
that no jobs were available for them
that increased 452,000 in January that's
not the sign of a strong labor market a
strong jobs Market that's not what we're
seeing so this report shows us job cuts
are happening layoffs are happening
hours are being reduced but wages are
increasing that could be all part of the
same Trend um listen when layoffs happen
they typically affect lower wage workers
and so when those lower wage workers are
laid off that brings up the average
earnings for a company if you make
$100,000 and I make $50,000 we work at
the same company well our average is$
755,000 but if I get laid off well now
our company's average is 100,000
similarly if I work 40 hours and you
work 20 hours and I get laid off our
average hours worked was 30 now it's 20
because you're the only one there think
about that as we're talking about the
labor market so what comes next well we
get the US Services PMI report on Monday
that's big we have seen solid numbers on
those PMI reports those purchasing
managers indexes or business surveys
that's going to be important on Monday
watch that Consumer Credit I keep
telling y' I'm pounding the table trying
to tell you to watch Consumer Credit
watch these delinquencies watch these
credit card numbers we are adding a lot
of debt personally to our balance sheets
here in the US watch those numbers
that's on Wednesday February 7th and
then on February 13th we'll be right
back here for Market takes make sure you
join us that's going to be a big one CPI
inflation February 13th 10 a.m. you're
going to want to be here don't be
anywhere else uh and for more check out
my podcast wsj's take on the week we cut
through the noise to explain the major
business and financial news that moves
markets also you can make smarter
investing decisions subscribe wherever
you get your podcast that's going to do
it for us here on Market takes hope
you'll be with us and join us when we do
it again next time